[Music]
you really enjoy social media very
popular on social media and you're very
active on Twitter and you you enjoy
using Twitter and creative ways I do I
follow this Twitter account called cute
emergency do you know it I've heard of
it but oh I'm sorry I asked you write it
I was just trying to take one little sip
you were like you asked me a question
you know I know cute emergency I'm not
talking necessary it's great I'm such an
idiot
what's cute emergency alright screw it
that's good I'll be right back and you
might as well alright oh you called
acute emergency and you click on it and
then you're happy because it'll be you
know like a puppy in a refrigerator like
what am I gonna eat tonight or like a
kitten in a bucket but sometimes they go
too far and it has the opposite effect
so I highly encourage you go there but
be careful if they cross the line into
too cute then you're enraged so so you
could be looking for having a you know I
need some cuteness it's an emergency and
you click on it actually makes you mad
you brought a couple of examples you
want to take us through these yeah these
are ones that made you mad is that
correct yeah okay let's take a look at
the first one
yeah just lines of their poor puppy
crotches it's too far they went too far
and now I'm the rage with you what's
move on let's see what's next
justyou're that's really really sure
what that is do you know what creature
that is Andy you're good at not I think
it's a rat I just think that I've heard
of those eggs I I yeah yes don't do that
with the Umbrella no no I got your drink
yeah okay we have what's next and just
now Mike guessing that a corn cob that
just is a very old woman and then I
think there's one more let's just take a
look and see wait a minute
- I disagree with you I'm totally I
think a little bunny that has a backpack
I love it this one filled me with so
much rage what do you do what is he
carrying in there what's a buddy got to
carry in there no it's like yourself oh
now you don't have to carry it the bunny
carry yeah
I gotta make a call fluffy get over
there get over here here's a carrot you
know
you